Hi everyone, it's Jerry. This is a Round 3
game from the 2016 Tata Steel chess tournament
between Wei Yi, playing on the white end,
and Magnus Carlsen. This is a pairing that
I've been looking forward to for about a year
now, since last year's Tata Steel tournament
where at the time Wei Yi was playing in the
Challenger's section. He went on to win that
which earned him the right to play in this
year's Master's section. So this game here
acts as the first meeting between these two.
Wei Yi, a 16-year-old from China, clearly
one of the most talented rising stars in our
game. He is paired against our current World
Chess Champion, the 25-year-old Magnus Carlsen
from Norway. Let's see what would happen in
this first of 'many' encounters? e4 e5 knight
f3, knight c6, bishop b5 entering the Ruy
Lopez or Spanish Game, a6, bishop a4. This
opening has a tendency to be a bit on the
positional side, or strategic side where play
is non-confrontational...not a lot of pawn
tension. The position does not open up. There
aren't early pawn exchanges. Rather both sides
develop slowly. Not the case here such that
the position does become sharp. It does...does
have tension in it...it does open up as early
as move 8. Knight f6, castles, bishop e7, rook
e1, b5, bishop b3, black castles, and after
c3...d5. So okay...here we are. This is a
sharp line in this opening, namely the Marshall
Attack. This is a gambit line. Black is with
this move offering up a pawn. Black with this
move is opening up the position, creating
pawn tension. And with this line black tries
to show that this backward, or delay in the
white development is an issue. e takes d,
knight takes, knight takes e. White's now
up a pawn. Knight takes knight, rook takes,
black secures the knight's post, d3. We're
a dozen moves in...well within opening theory...neither
player caught off guard...well within both
players preparation. Both players up until
this point have actually gained time on their
clocks. They started out with 100 minutes
each. With the time controls in this tournament,
you gain 30 seconds per move. So observing
the clock times on this side...going from
one move to the next does give us some insight
as to how much time is spent on each move.
Now with this last move in the game, d3...this
is the first question I had for myself. I
have seen the move d3, I have also seen the
move d4, and until I spent the time investigating
it further...ya know I didn't have a reason,
or I couldn't identify or share with you a
difference between the two until now. The
move d4, I must say to me at least, and probably
for many...d4 seems much more natural. Why
not go two instead of one? Why not have a
pawn watch over a pawn instead of devoting
a piece to its defense? So what's a difference
between having the pawn on d3 and d4? Well let
me show you one difference. There's some tactical
idea involved. If the pawn is on d4...it's
quite common and this is played just in all
variations...just in this system...in this
opening the bishop does reposition and get
on this diagonal with tempo, challenging the
rook. If the pawn is on d4, we do have bishop
d6, and the queen can come out to h4. After
g3 to defend against h2, she goes deeper into
the white position. This is a very strong
post for the black queen, and one that white
may try to disrupt. For example with rook
to e4. Trying to play rook h4 to challenge
that queen's post. However this can be prevented
with the move g5...a super committal move...a
very weakening move. But it does a good job
in preventing rook h4, and it is poison. It
cannot be captured...should not be captured.
Bishop takes g5 can be met with queen f5,
striking at not just one, but two unprotected
pieces. Knight d2, queen takes bishop. This
is not available if...this g5 move is not
available if the pawn is on d3. Bishop d6,
queen h4, queen h3, rook e4, g5 to stop this
idea is no good. Bishop takes pawn can be
played because queen f5 strikes at only one,
not two unprotected pieces. Anyhow just wanted
to share one of the differences between these
two. Okay so in the game it was d3, bishop
d6, rook e1, bishop f5 striking at d3. Queen
f3 strikes at the bishop...this is ignored.
Black sets their sights on h2. If white is
grabbing the bishop, this is a very strong
attack that black has. Not a good idea for
white to grab the material. Development is
key, and there's little of it on the queenside.
g3 simply parries the threat. Queen h3, bishop
e3 offers the pawn back and it is taken. If
white is doing something other than bishop
to e3...ya know as it stands right now black
has that direct...this direct connection between
the rooks...the thing that we look to do when
we play...to have all our pieces cleared out
between our rooks. White is two moves away
from having similar. If knight d2 is played,
white is still two moves away from finishing
development. The knight still has to move
and the bishop still has to move. So white
is offering up the pawn in order to complete
development. Bishop e3 with then knight to
d2 is the idea that white has. Black gets
that material back. White finishes development.
And now black plays queen to f5. I should
mention that on bishop to e3, it isn't a good
idea for black to say ya know what I'm going
to take this opportunity to grab the bishop
pair...knight takes bishop. Because white
can recapture, move forward, improve the rook
position, prepare to double, and have security
over the d3 pawn. That pawn with live. White
will maintain that pawn plus. Not a good idea
to take the bishop in this position as soon
as it plays to e3. Nor is it a good position...a
good idea to take the bishop after knight
to d2. Knight takes here is also not a good
idea because after rook takes the bishop is
hit, and white can next take on c6 with the
queen. Bishop g6, queen takes c6. The development
on the white side is fine, and white has still
that pawn plus. Some care of course needs
to be taken over these weaknesses near the
kingside, but not a good idea to be taking
knight takes bishop there. Only after queen
f5 is this now some threat...knight takes
bishop. Black is preparing to exchange queens,
which would rule out that earlier mentioned
queen takes c6 move, and only then take the
bishop. So black threatens to exchange queens
and then take the bishop with this last move.
So white gets out of the way only at this
point, bishop d4. There is no knight takes
bishop, the rook is now unmasked. Rook a to
e8, king to g2, improving the king position
slightly. Queen takes queen, king takes. You
could take with the knight, but it may be
a little bit uncomfortable. This is the thing
that I think about when...if the knight is
capturing I see a move like bishop to e4 and
I see that I'm in a pin and I can't resolve
that pin so easily. You could resolve it in
time with something like rook a1* (c1), and
then bishop to c2, but just to recognize some
of the uncomfortableness...if that's even
a word. Some ya know of the discomfort let's
say that white can experience if they're taking
on f3 with the knight instead of the king.
So in the game it was king takes queen, rook
to e6. And if we observe the clock times...Carlsen
has spent very little time. In fact, ya know,
this last move seems like it was played pretty,
ya know, pretty quick and probably within
his preparation still here. And I'm highlighting
this because it may have influenced this next
move by white (Wei Yi). It seems...it may
seem appealing to just grab this rook. It
does allow this discovered check, but you
move the king out of the way and there's maybe...ya
know is this a liability...ya know something
that can be exploited having now this isolated
pawn? Well things can get quite sharp from here.
So if white (Wei Yi) was not prepared, if
they have not seen this position before...if
they have not looked at it before with a computer...it
makes some sense to not go in this direction...into
this sharp line where black is throwing some
punches, and ya know if you're not careful...ya
know things can quite easily go bad. My point
here is Carlsen seems to be, with this last
move, the more prepared side. So entering
a sharp line...maybe not a good idea. And
this is a sharp line. So we don't have this
capture on e6, but instead rook a to c1, which
is prepping this c4 move. The c4 move can
be played right away...this is an important
question you might have. I'm pointing out
well rook a to c1 is preparing this...well
why not just break with c4 right away?...you
have enough support for it. If we look at
c4 right away...this is a move. The idea with
this can be to, ya know, try and disrupt the
knight position. If pawn takes...this would
be...this would be good for white because
the bishop can recapture. And what is the
end result of the b-pawn being exchanged for
the c-pawn? Well black now has some deficient
queenside structure...two isolated pawns.
Black however can actually move the knight,
and have this move in mind. For example after
c takes b, the rook is hit, but black doesn't
have to react to that. They can play a takes
b, and allow the rook to be captured. Because
after the recapture there's a check. If king
g2, knight c2 wins the material back. This
would not be the case if the rook was on c1.
It gets a little bit more involved from this
position. After king to e3, there's moves
like c5, and black playing a line where they're
an exchange down but they have very active
pieces. I don't want to show that. I don't
want to go too far astray from the actual
game. But that's...those are some of the points...this
knight b4 reaction in reply to c4 right now
instead of...after having the rook on c1.
Okay, in the game we did have rook a to c1,
not this c4 strike. Black now plays a6, or
excuse me h6, this is a flight square for
the black king. I should also mention this
rook a to c1 move does not allow this quite
natural doubling on the e-file. This is, ya
know, if we have a look at this move...the
move played was this, h6. But if black is
doing something super natural like a rook
f to e8, doubling rooks, what can follow is
the exchange of rooks, and then this c4 move
and this is very good for white (Wei Yi).
Not a winning advantage, but there is some...white
is definitely the preferred side here with
this variation. The knight is hit. If the
knight moves right away, now this is no good.
c takes b, there aren't those tricks of bishop
takes rook, and then the pawn recapturing
with check in this case. This is an issue
for black (Magnus Carlsen). So you actually
do have to take on c4 right away. You can't
make a knight move. And after bishop takes,
bishop takes, knight takes, it can only be
white who is fighting for a...ya know white
is the preferred side here. For what reasons?
Well, structural standpoint, queenside, these
are deficient, two isolated queenside pawns.
If you wanna take it one step further, compare
king positions. This is a better king position,
this is an endgame, the kings wanna be closer
towards the center, and this is a better positioned
white king. Okay, so the natural rook f to
e8...not a good idea. Instead h6, still having
this idea in mind where if the rook is captured
in some way, this is this recapture with a
discovered check. White (Wei Yi) gets out
of that altogether, tucks the king away, king
g2. Rook g6 gets out of the line of fire of
the bishop for one, and places the pawn in
a pin which is now permitting a knight f4
check. This is something that white allows.
Knight e4 is played. About 18 minutes was
spent on this move knight to e4. A continuation
that was likely thought about in this position
was the bishop for knight exchange...this
is a big deal in the game. Just ya, in a chess
game the bishop for knight exchange is a big
deal...a big imbalance to try an assess. White
could have gone for this, to give up the light-squared
bishop for the knight on d5, and then look
to next quickly eliminate this trump that
black has, which is to say the bishop pair
by playing bishop to e5. If the bishop's running
away, you can look to try and hunt him down
in this way. If he's avoiding these exchanges,
these pieces can take up some nice posts.
This is a direction that the game could have
gone...the bishop for knight exchange I imagine
that was at least one of the things...one
of the variations that was considered here...to
take the knight and then find a good post
for this knight. He would have a good square
to rely upon in that of the d4 square. He
did not go for this. Instead improves the
knight position, and strikes at the d6 bishop,
allows knight to f4, and this does hit. Knight
f4 check, king moves forward, bishop takes
knight, rook takes, knight d3 striking at
both rook and pawn. You move the rook and
defend the pawn right? You could do that.
But white instead stays very active with the
rooks...centralizes the rook. Rook to d1 allows
the pawn to be captured. Rook d2...so this
is a good post for the rook, it's an active
post, striking at the knight, he's on an open
file. White is now down a pawn, has however
the bishop pair, well centralized rooks, and
a better king position in this ending. Bishop
a3 to defend, bishop to b6 clearing the rook
to maybe enter here along...well rook to d7
is an idea, but also it's clearing the way
for the rook to observe these two jumping
points by the knight. Rook to d6, rook takes
rook, bishop takes, rook to e2, knight to
d3. If the knight is immediately going here
we can expect a quick capture, and then the
rook getting very active. Rook to d2, bishop
to e5, rook to e2, bishop to d6. This may
also even be an idea...going straight in for
rook to e4 instead of questioning the bishop's
position like this of rook to d2 to e2. Simply
rook to e4* hunting down this pawn like this.
Rook e4...rook e4 to c4. So knight c4 was
not played. Knight d3 instead, rook d2, knight
to e5 hitting with a check, king goes back
to g2. Bishop e7...that bishop was hit by
the rook, now f4. Yeah, the knight does not
have very many options, he goes into c4. Going
to, let's say, g4, yeah this let's the rook
enter, strike at the bishop. White will likely
grab one of the...will likely regain the material,
and still have these two bishops in an open
position. Not a good idea...not a good idea
for the knight to play to g4, or even g6 for
that matter. He's just as good on g6 as he
is off the board. So knight c4, bishop takes
knight, pawn takes, there's been a lot of
back and forth...a little back and forth here
with one side being up material, then giving
it back. I mean, how did it play out so far?
Black played the gambit line, white was up
a pawn, white gave the pawn back, black was
up a pawn, and then black is basically giving
the pawn back here. In each case there's this...ya
know, when you're up the pawn you're pieces
aren't as well positioned...you're kind of
on your heels. And then in order to get off
your heels, you give that material back to
release the pressure. And that continued to
shift back and forth like that from a white
side to black side, black side to white side.
We had that little shift going on in many
cases in this game so far. As it stands right
now, black is up a pawn. It's not a super
healthy pawn of course, but it is a pawn...a
situation of double isolated pawns here, but
white has rook activity...do a rook comparison
here. White is also on move, playing rook
to d7. Bishop f6, rook c7, bishop takes c,
rook takes c. Black is still up a pawn, but
white has rook activity...better pieces. Rook
to b8, a4, bishop to b2, bishop to a5. Number
1 priority...get rid of this passed pawn.
c3, bishop takes, bishop takes, rook takes,
rook to b4, and now how to react to this pressure
against the pawn? Well, it's a5. That is the
best move. Rook to a3...on rook to a3 black
can play a5 and be one step further...one
step closer to queening should this pawn fall.
So first it's best to play a5, and only then
rook to a3. If this pawn is captured, at least
this guy has to work a little bit harder to
get to his desired a1 square. So a5, in other
words...when the pawn is hit, a5. Only at this
point, rook to a3. Rook check, king moves
forward. You could play back here but it's
a little bit scary to have your king cut off
from the action. White is instead moving forward.
f5, rook c3 looks to transfer the rook. Looks
to also win the a6 pawn. So black needs to
get back to a position where they put pressure
on the pawn. Does that after rook c3, rook
b5. This is the best way to put pressure on
this pawn. If you're doing it by way of a2,
the rook plays to c5, and this is a much more
active post for the rook to defend the pawn
when you compare that with the rook playing
to a3. This is far more defensive, this is
a better post. Defense, and he also has some
aggressive intentions from c5. So after this
rook to c3 move, it is rook to, excuse me
rook to c3, rook b5 is played next. Rook to
a3, g5, f takes, h takes, king to g2, king
g7, h4, g4, and now white says I'm not just
gonna stay here and defend my pawn. I'm going
to allow you to take it, and while you grab
that material, I am going to improve my rook
position. Rook c3, rook takes a, rook c6 cuts
the king off. Rook check, king g1. a5, white
gets right behind the pawn, a4, king h1. Black
is up a pawn. The game started out early where
white was up a pawn, but we had that lot of
back and forth...shifting of material...the
shifting of piece activity. King h1, king
f7. There's not a good way forward for either
side here. White stays around here with the
king, and the rook stays on a6...ideally placed
to be behind...he's ideally placed because
he is behind the passed pawn, and he is cutting
off the king from moving forward. King h1,
a3, king g1, and it is at this point that
the players agreed to a draw. There's not
a good way forward here. If black is trying
to improve the king position towards the center,
he will have to first go in this direction.
But this is not such a good idea. If black
is trying something like this, we can play
king h1, and as soon as the king plays here...actually
yeah after the king plays here we can push
h5, and the king will not be able to stop
the pawn, so guess who's going to have to
do that? The rook, and when he does, this
pawn is taken. Even if we have this exchange
of the h-pawn for the a-pawn, this will not
be enough to win. This is an easily holdable
draw for white. One pawn versus two. So there's
really just no way forward here. Black could
give a check...after a2...after king to g1,
if black is giving a check, king g2, and then
playing a2, white can do basically whatever...just
keep the king sitting here, and keep the rook
trained on this pawn like this. If the king
ever gets down to this point where he is defending
the pawn, you could just give a check, and
then get right back over here to keep pressure
against the a2 pawn. But there's even more
serious issues that black would have to tend
to in such cases. This is a connected passed
pawn, so there's really no way forward, and
again after this king to g1 move...move 60,
the players agreed to a draw. So, interesting
first encounter between these two. What are
your thoughts on the future of maybe these
two players battling? I was looking forward
to this game. I know it ended as a draw...not
the result that most players would really like
to see. You usually like to see a win or a
loss...a decisive result. But yeah, interesting
game between Wei Yi, a very young talent,
and our current world chess champion Magnus
Carlsen. So feel free to leave any feedback,
as usual, to this video. And as usual I hope
you got something out of it. That's all for
now. Take care, bye.